en el último vídeo los desafío que
escribieran múltiples funciones y
bonacci para calcular un término de la
sucesión de fibonacci ya sea funciones
interactivas o recursivas y aquí les
daré una ayuda y les mostraré en los
siguientes vídeos que hay muchas maneras
de hacer esto y creativamente déjenme
definir una función fibonacci fibonacci
y tendrá el parámetro n este es el
parámetro que le pasaremos a la función
y sabemos que por definición los
primeros dos términos de la sucesión de
fibonacci son 0 y 1 así que hagamos una
lista esto es muy interesante es la
primera vez que haremos una especie de
manipulación con listas así que los
términos aquí son el término cero en la
sucesión de fibonacci es 0 y el primer
término es 1 por definición y aquí
tenemos algo así como el corazón de
nuestro código y luego lo que vamos a
hacer es construir esta lista con todos
los elementos incluyendo el término n y
regresar el término n de esta lista y la
razón por la que voy a hacerlo de esta
manera es porque es simple ahorrar
memoria en todos los números de
fibonacci y una lista es útil para
calcular cada incremento de la sucesión
de gen hacerlo de esta manera voy a usar
el ciclo while ustedes pueden usar el
ciclo for pero para mí el ciclo baile es
más natural en este
antes de definir el ciclo while tengo
que definir la variable para la
iteración y voy a usar la variable y la
voy a hacer igual a cero vamos a ver
cómo funciona en un momento luego while
y es menor o igual a n y va a empezar en
cero y va a ir incrementándose a esta n
dubz en realidad y no debería empezar en
cero porque ya tenemos el término cero
aquí y el primer término aquí y lo que
queremos hacer es construir el segundo
tercero y todos los demás hasta el
término n entonces voy a empezar y en
dos como ya tengo aquí el término cero y
el primer término lo que voy a hacer es
calcular el segundo término por eso
tengo que empezar con igualados y todos
los que faltan hasta llegar al término n
es por eso que tengo aquí en el ciclo
while y menor o igual que n vamos a
continuar agregando elementos a esta
secuencia así que mientras si sea menor
o igual a n voy a tomar esta lista que
tengo aquí y agregar elementos al final
de la lista
usando una función
para cualquier lista en python happened
y lo están aprendiendo aquí y lo pueden
ver la ventana de ayuda me dice cómo
usarlo y puedo agregar al final de esta
lista otro término y el siguiente
término que voy a agregar al final de la
lista es la suma de los dos anteriores
así es la sucesión de fibonacci entonces
va a ser términos y menos 1
este es el término previo literalmente
términos y menos 1 es el término previo
más términos y menos 2 esencialmente
esta instrucción es lo que va a
construir la asociación de fibonacci en
esta lista y luego vamos a incrementar y
es igual a más 1 si no incrementamos si
este ciclo se ejecutaría para siempre
pero tenemos que incrementar y para que
se siga calculando la sucesión y
lleguemos a un punto en el que y no sea
menor o igual a n y el ciclo pueda
terminar y cuando terminemos de ejecutar
el ciclo podamos entonces regresar el
término
de la asociación cuando el ciclo se
rompa entonces vamos a la siguiente
instrucción que es regresar el término n
de la asociación de fibonacci return
términos n regresamos el término n de la
lista términos
veamos si esto funciona si esto tiene
sentido así que calculamos los términos
de la sucesión hasta el término n y
realmente esto debe funcionar porque si
nos piden el elemento 0 fibonacci de 0
nos regresa el término 0 que es cero si
nos piden fibonacci de 1 nos regresa
este término de aquí que es 1 no es el 0
sino el 1 así que parece que si va a
funcionar y antes de correrlo quiero que
estén seguros que entienden lo que
estamos haciendo con la lista así que
voy a enseñarles aquí abajo con un
ejemplo cómo funciona esta lista voy a
definir una lista como a igual a 1,2
esta es mi lista y si luego tecleo
puedo ver mi lista y luego tecleo a
apuntó up en 7 entonces para ver lo que
pasó tecleo ahí puedo ver este 7 al
final de la lista si quiero ver los
elementos de la lista tecleo a de 0 el
elemento 0 de la lista es igual a 1 si
quiero ver el elemento dos de la lista
tecleo a y usando brackets tecleo el 2 y
es igual a 7 y esto es exactamente lo
que estoy haciendo acá arriba le estoy
diciendo que agregue al final de la
lista un nuevo elemento que será igual a
la suma de los términos previos en la
primera vez del ciclo y es 2 entonces y
menos 1 es 1 así que va a sumar el
término 1 más el término 0 y el término
1 tiene un valor de 1 y el término 0
tiene un valor de 0 y va a seguir
haciendo esto hasta que calculé el
término n y veremos en el siguiente
vídeo un ejemplo particular pero ahora
vamos
a correr el programa para ver si
realmente funciona
voy a correrlo
ok vamos a ver si nos regresa a los
resultados correctos empecemos desde el
principio fibonacci de 0 a 0 es correcto
hagamos fibonacci de 1
es correcto fibonacci de 2 también es 1
también es correcto si bonacci de 3 esto
debería ser 2 porque estamos sumando 11
si funciona hagamos fibonacci de 10 ok
se ve bien tratemos de buenache de algo
enorme fibonacci de 100
ok este es un número muy grande y no voy
a entrar ahora en este tipo de números
flotantes super largos pero tratemos con
algo más pequeño hagamos fibonacci de 20
así que parece que si funciona y lo
pueden verificar por ustedes mismos
bueno esto es solo una implementación de
la función fibonacci y en los siguientes
vídeos voy a tratar otra forma de
hacerlo tal vez con el ciclo force o tal
vez lo haré recursiva mente